eu tomei a decisão mais difícil da minha
vida eu comecei a empresa dez anos no
quartinho da minha casa trabalhando
sozinha me formei em publicidade
vim pra ponta grossa e dos campos gerais
trabalha numa agência ganha conta por
causa de um namorado
abri uma empresa com este laboral e
comecei a cursar administração por causa
desse namorar porque pegava muito no meu
pé eo namoro não estava bem mas eu amava
o que fazer e por causa da empresa que
eu tinha eu aprendi aquele namoro
então eu tomei a decisão de sair de um
relacionamento e no mesmo dia
eu não tinha namorado e eu não tinha
emprego
eu fiquei quase um ano desempregada
fiz muitos processos seletivos empresas
multinacionais e veículos de comunicação
importantes e eu ia muito bem nas
entrevistas mas nem nada deu certo
porque não era pra dar certo
eu comecei a falar como eu fazia
faculdade de administração eu comecei a
fazer estágio com o consultor e
palestrante
eu ajudava a montar as palestras e
participar dos treinamentos
eu acompanhava nas consultorias e assim
acabei me tornando uma consultora de
empresas e aos poucos também foi
conquistando clientes porque eu fui a
primeira publicitário formado dos campos
gerais e comecei a conquistar clientes
comecei a trabalhar na minha casa montei
meu escritório no quartinho do meu
apartamento e ao invés de eu falar
apartamento 24 era sala 24 e quando
tocava o telefone e pediu para falar com
o presidente
eu falava só um minutinho e atendia
novamente então era da faxineira
presidente e as coisas foram acontecendo
fui por um ponto ou sociedades
os clientes começaram a surgir os
funcionários e as coisas aconteciam e eu
amava aquilo que eu fazia
com o passar dos anos isso começou a
perder o colorido e essa ficha caiu
quando eu voltando de férias cheguei no
tremo da cidade de ponta grossa e vi uma
descarga de energia de angústia e
ansiedade por ter que voltar a trabalhar
e eu pensei isso não está certo porque
eu estou sentindo isso é uma empresa é o
que eu amo e de repente o meu trabalho
começou a perder o significado de
repente a empreendedora admirada não via
mais graça no seu trabalho e assumir
isso pra mim foi o processo mais difícil
e posso dizer que levou alguns anos
poderá assumir que eu não queria mais
pra entender esse sentimento comecei a
conversar com alguns amigos consultores
com alguns amigos empresários alguns
amiga alguns clientes
conversei com minha família e tomei a
decisão porque cada pessoa que eu
conversava me dava uma nova peça pra mim
é para que aquilo se construísse dentro
de mim
com apoio da minha família eu comecei a
tomar as ações para que isso acontecesse
conversei com a equipe o meu plano a de
vender não deu certo
o meu plano b das a equipe assume também
não deu certo
meu plano a alá que era da minha sócia
seguir também não deu certo porque nesse
mesmo período a mãe dela ficou doente e
alguns meses depois faleceu de câncer e
eu decidi fechar porque eu não tinha
mais como me enganar
simplesmente porque nasci em mim o
desejo de viver um novo o desejo de
viver uma nova história
o desejo de viver novos sonhos o desejo
de me descobrir porque dentro da minha
empresa agora eu me sentia presa
então veio o aviso para os funcionários
comecei a conversar com os clientes
rompendo contratos tentando ajudar da
melhor forma possível para que essa
transição acontecesse sem dores mas
saibam que isso não é possível porque a
partir do momento que você toma decisões
você afeta vidas de pessoas
comecei a avisar os fornecedores e ao
mesmo tempo uma tristeza profunda e um
choro de quase uma semana tomou conta de
mim
conversando com a amiga psicóloga ela
fez entender eu estava vivendo um
processo de luto luto por estar velando
aquela empresa que por muitas vezes
tomou o lugar de um casamento e de
filhos que até hoje eu não tenho
luto por uma empresa que muitas vezes
toma o lugar no tempo junto com a minha
família e tomar o lugar de um tempo pra
mim mesmo pois muitas vezes abre mão de
vida social abre mão de me cuidar porque
eu estava totalmente mergulhado naquela
empresa entendido isso tamos viver bem o
nosso luto
um amigo me dá um conselho que foi
importante é um amigo advogado onde eu
fui quando eu fui pedir informações
algumas dúvidas trabalhistas ele falou
fica tranquilo tranquilo você está
fazendo tudo certo mas eu quero te dar
um conselho e olhou no meu olho e falou
você vai me prometer que você vai
colocar um batom nessa boca um salto
nesses pés e vai levantar a cabeça
porque você sabe a profissional que você
é e você é uma profissional reconhecida
e todo mundo sabe do teu talento
então você vai fazer o favor de tirar da
tua cabeça essa palavra que está
rondando aí que pode ser fracasso
isso não existe porque você é digna de
aplausos e o que você está fazendo é o
que muita gente tem vontade e não tem
coragem
então faça o que eu estou dizendo fui
ver meu luto de salto alto e batom na
boca
passei uma numa floricultura comprei
flores pra mim mesma
um cartão bem brega eu te amo você é o
máximo e vamos pra frente
é esperar de carnaval
eu virei a chave peguei essas coisas
entreguei a chave e fui para casa na
quinta feira quando eu voltei a
trabalhar não sabia acordei não sabia o
que fazer
minha casa cheia de caixas sem uma
rotina e tendo que me reinventar e aí
que começa a questionar o título da
minha palestra
não tenha medo de começar do zero onde
eu trocaria ela por não tenha medo de
voltar para 10
por que voltar para 10 porque eu
precisei reduzir sobre quem era eu
novamente é não tem como você encontrar
o significado não tem como você
encontrará a felicidade na sua vida
quando você não descobre quem é você e
olhando pra essa estrada
eu me deparei no colo do meu pai é
novinha e olhei pra eles e vi que eles
quando eu nasci era muito mais novos do
que eu estava o que eu sou hoje
e hoje eu me sinto ainda inexperiente
para assumir o que eles assumiram
naquela época eu me olho e penso que
naquele momento eu era pura luz por amor
e pura alegria é provavelmente foi lá
que eu fui criada e foi lá neste momento
é que começa a minha missão aqui na
terra
quando deus lá de cima olha essa alma
iluminada e fala é hora de descer eu
falei eu quero ir e não tem como a gente
ser feliz seja não entender qual é a
nossa missão nesse mundo qual é o nosso
propósito
por isso pra voltar para 10 eu precisei
voltar para aquela caminhonete onde tudo
começou e entender o quê
por muito tempo os meus pais nem falavam
e talvez eu não compreendia
quando ele falava você não é todo mundo
acredita que alguns aqui já devo ter
patrão ouvido isso é que eu me dei conta
que esse foi o conselho mais maravilhoso
que eles poderiam ter me dado quando
eles estavam contando que eu não
precisava ser todo mundo que eu não
precisava viver na média que eu não
precisava fazer o que todo mundo fazia
que eu não precisava ter uma vida
medíocre porque viver na média ter uma
vida medíocre e essa essa lição fez eu
entender como a gente precisa fazer
diferença na vida para poder ter uma
vida extraordinária e é o meu momento de
transformação aconteceu por trabalhar
essas três sentimentos alienação
vergonha e mediocridade alienação por
entender por que é quando nós não
entendemos não buscamos sair do nosso
piloto automático da nossa vida comum de
tudo aquilo que nós somos acostumados a
fazer vergonha na minha opinião o pior
sentimento que pode existir porque é
moldar a vida sob o olhar do outro e
desde lá eu tenho lutado contra a
vergonha ea mediocridade não levar uma
vida na média e tentar passar das trevas
para a luz
sendo uma pessoa autêntica com amor
próprio e madura que ainda não sou vai
demorar porque isso é algo que nós é
somente que nós conseguimos nos amar
plenamente nos respeitar plenamente e
nos valorizar plenamente que conseguiu
conseguiremos ser pessoas maduras para
poder se olhar no espelho e entender
quem você é realmente o que você faz da
vida o que você quer da vida o que você
acredita e tem a ousadia de viver e ser
aquilo que você está vendo no espelho e
se você não gosta daquilo que você vê no
espelho ter a ousadia
de mudar aquilo que você vê no espelho
mas principalmente consegui olhar no
espelho e não olhar o externo
mas olhar o interno essa é uma frase na
caneca que eu ganhei que alguém e
descreveu assim humanidade cotidiana
inspiradora vontade de viver o novo e
essa sou eu e essa frase você nasceu pra
ser missão quando eu escutei essa frase
ela transformou algo dentro de mim
porque nós costumamos pensar que nós
temos uma missão mas bem a verdade é que
nós somos lição e nós podemos emissão na
nossa casa no nosso trabalho com os
nossos amigos
a todo instante este menino que vocês
estão vendo ele se chama alberto
eu sou a única amiga que ele tem ele não
sai de casa
ele tem paralisia cerebral e eu vou aos
domingos pegar ele para levar a missa
porque uma amiga convidou é que era o
sonho dele a missa e eu fui lá e no
primeiro domingo e ver ele a missa o meu
sentimento era de que eu era jesus
levando jesus para ver jesus
eu nunca me senti tão realizada na minha
vida do que se nesse momento que eu
peguei esse menino e levei ele para a
missa
essa minha amiga márcia ela luta com
câncer há 15 anos ela já tirou seios ela
já tirou a perna amputada a perna e
agora ela já está perdendo a voz lucas
câncer no meio de estilo mas eu jamais
vi ela tirar o sorriso do rosto
e essas pessoas me fazem lembrar que o
que é uma vida com o significado o que é
uma vida comissão e o que é uma vida com
propósito
se vocês observarem nessas fotos eu
estou com a mesma camiseta porque era a
camiseta que eu vestia quando eu fui
levar o alberto a primeira vez na missa
e essa camiseta representa a minha
melhor versão
e essa noite eu quero da minha melhor
versão pra vocês porque eu quero
terminar minha palestra
vestindo a minha camiseta por aqui
porque eu nasci pra ser missão e eu
nasci pra inspirar pessoas todos os dias
tem uma frase que eu escutei de um amigo
o servente de pedreiro e quando ele me
falou ele não tinha noção da dada a
grandiosidade que ele estava ensinando
quando ele falou essa frase quem tem fé
tem coragem e isso é mais pura verdade
você só vai ter coragem de fazer o que
você precisa fazer quando você tiver fé
tiver fé em você mesmo de fé naquilo que
você quer acreditar porque não é
possível mover se tomar iniciativa ou
fazer qualquer coisa
se você não tiver fé então se a tua fé
está adormecida
se a tua fé está enfraquecida
busque dentro de você porque deus mora
dentro de você busque dentro de você e
você será capaz de fazer qualquer coisa
na sua vida e você será capaz de começar
do zero quantas vezes forem necessárias
e você será capaz de voltar 100 quantas
vezes forem necessárias
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]